blood father stars Mel Gibson as an
ex-con ex-alcoholic who's trying to
clean up his life when his estranged
missing daughter shows up on his
doorstep saying that she's got some
serious problems so we have a father who
is just now trying to clean up his life
he has been through the emotional and
physical wringer and all of a sudden his
daughter's showing up with all these
problems and all of this baggage and
this isn't usual father daughter arguing
this is holy shit an entire gang is
after me and I'm going to be shot and
killed and probably a lot of other
things that I don't want to have
happened to me dad please save me so
this father is trying to protect his
daughter from these horrible people
we've seen plots like this before what
elevates this movie beyond your typical
b-movie that you would see that's like
this is Gibson he's fantastic in this
movie he's very charismatic he looks
like a humongous bear I've never seen
him this big muscle mass wise he's huge
in this movie and he definitely sells
this role he has a really funny rapport
with William H Macy who plays his
sponsor who's trying to help him get off
of alcohol there's a grizzled demeanor
about his character that is so intense
and so hard-edged and Gibson really
brought that this is the best work I've
seen from him in quite some time and I
hesitate to say this but this might
actually be one of the better
performances I've seen in 2016 and I
mean that in all honesty the guy blew me
away in this film he's fantastic
the other thing this movie really got
right was that relationship between him
and his daughter it starts out very very
rough for a number of reasons this girl
is completely effed up and he is seeing
someone so broken possibly even more
broken as a person than he is and he
just wants to find some way to be that
father for her that he never was before
and it's captured so well in this movie
that it's actually kind of heartbreaking
at times and it truly caught me off
guard in the best of ways now this movie
is marketed as an action movie and in
some ways it is it does feel almost kind
of grindhouse like there's a very
low-budget sense to this movie that
works in its favor not as a hindrance
but I would hesitate to call this an
action movie it's more of a drama with
action in it and I love that about this
movie because I don't need wall-to-wall
action for a story to work and these
characters are what made this story work
the movie started out really strong the
pacing was excellent but then the second
act it dipped down a bit when he visits
some old buddies that he's no longer
friends with because these guys are like
the worst of the worst of humanity
there's about a 10 to 15-minute lull in
the excitement and the drama of this
film where there isn't that much
character building happening and there's
a little bit of preaching going on that
felt unnecessary but then it picked up
again in an explosive confrontation and
I was like holy shit
Gibson uh where have you been Wow there
are times in this movie where he just
loses his shit
and goes full-on Mad Max and it was
riveting after that brief lull though in
the second act it picks up quite a bit
for the third act an actor I had no idea
was in this movie shows up and I was
really excited about that this movie
really surprised me it is a very fun
action drama with excellent performances
a very good relationship between a
father and a daughter and just a fun
time at the movies I saw this at the
only theater in my area showing it in
Mentor Ohio about 40 miles away from my
house I made the trek they gave me that
poster thank you to that theater it was
like stepping back in time they had
these old arcades that were 25 cents
they had all these old posters up from
like seven years ago or so it was really
cool actually I had a good time with
blood father it is by no means a classic
but it is a well acted fun dramatic
action movie with a great comeback
performance from Mel Gibson I'm gonna
give blood father a B+ if it's playing
in a theater near you or it's on VOD
come not sure if it is but if it is
check it out because I don't want this
movie to fly underneath people's radars
it's pretty good guys thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes